♪ ♪
>> Tucker: THE QUESTION IS,
DID BILL CLINTON VISIT HIS CLOSE
FRIEND JEFF OR JERRY EPSTEIN’S
ISLAND, "PEDO" ISLAND, WITH TWO
YOUNG GIRLS?
COURT DOCUMENTS SUGGEST HE DID.
WHY ISN’T IT FRONT PAGE
JUDGE JEANINE PIRRO HAS
THOUGHTS.
GREAT TO SEE YOU.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT, HERE’S THE
BOTTOM LINE.
DO THEY CARE ABOUT BILL CLINTON
WHEN HE WAS ENGAGING IN
SEXUAL RELATIONS IN THE
OVAL OFFICE WITH AN INTERN?
NO, DID THEY APOLOGIZE FRIEND
MIA, YES, DOES THE MAINSTREAM
MEDIA CONTINUE TO FORGIVE HIM
YES.
IF IT WAS A REPUBLICAN WOULD BE
TOTALLY DIFFERENT.
BUT WE HAVE HEARD ABOUT THIS
EPSTEIN CASE, WE HEARD ABOUT
DEMOCRATS.
BILL RICHARDSON, GEORGE
MITCHELL, BILL CLINTON.
EVERYBODY SAYS NO, BILL WAS
NEVER ON THE PLANE EXCEPT HE’S
ON THE MANIFEST 26 TIMES.
AND THEN THEY SAY NO HE WAS NOT
IN THE ISLAND WE NOW HAVE
TESTIMONY.
IDENTIFICATION EVIDENCE BY
VIRGINIA ROBERTS WHO SAYS HE WAS
ON THE ISLAND WITH TWO YOUNG
GIRLS.
AND THEN EVIDENCE IS SIGNIFICANT
AND THEY CAN CALL VIRGINIA
ROBERTS A LIAR UNTIL THE COWS
COME HOME.
BUT SHE’S THE WOMAN WHO IS A
PICTURE OF YOURSELF AT THE AGE
OF 17 WITH PRINCE ANDREW’S ARM
AROUND HER WAIST IN SOMEONE’S
HOME WITH GHISLAINE MAXWELL
LOOKING AT HER.
GHISLAINE MAXWELL OF COURSE WE
FIND OUT WHAT A MONSTER SHE IS.
SHE NOT ONLY ARRANGED ALL OF
THIS, SHE SOUGHT OUT GIRLS WHO
WERE VULNERABLE.
SHE GROOMED THEM.
SHE TAUGHT THEM HOW TO TAKE
CARE, HOW TO MASSAGE MEN AND
TAKE CARE OF THEM BUT IN
ADDITION TO ALL OF THAT IN
ADDITION TO SCARRING THESE YOUNG
GIRLS FOR LIFE, SHE ALSO ENGAGED
IN THESE UNDERAGE.
SHE IS A MONSTER.
FOR ALL THOSE PEOPLE WHO SAID
SHE SHOULD GET BAIL.
NO.
SHE IS AS BAD AS EPSTEIN AND THE
FACT THAT SHE’S CONTINUING TO
SAY THAT SHE DIDN’T DO ANYTHING,
IT’S ABSURD BECAUSE THERE WERE
SO MANY VICTIMS IN THIS CASE AND
I’VE GOT TO ADD ONE MORE THING,
TUCKER BECAUSE I KNOW ARE SHORT
ON TIME.
NOW YOU INTERVIEWED
ALAN DERSHOWITZ ON FRIDAY.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I FIND
STANDING IS THAT ALAN DERSHOWITZ
ACTUALLY SAYS YOU KNOW, IT WAS
REALLY ONLY TWO MISDEMEANORS
THAT WE REPRESENTED HIM ON IN
FLORIDA.
YES, TWO MISDEMEANORS WITH 13
VICTIMS.
AND THEN HE SAYS YOU KNOW I
DIDN’T REALLY KNOW HIM THAT WELL
EXCEPT HE STAYED IN HIS HOUSE.
AND THEN DERSHOWITZ SAYS I WAS
NEVER INVOLVED IN THAT PART OF
THE PLEA AGREEMENT THAT INVOLVES
A NONPROSECUTION OF UNIDENTIFIED
INDIVIDUALS IN THE FUTURE SHOULD
THEY EVER BE PROSECUTED FOR ANY
CRIMES INVOLVED WITH ME,
CONSPIRATORS WITH ME WHO I
SUSPECT IS GHISLAINE MAXWELL
ALONG WITH A WHOLE HOST OF MEN,
POWERFUL RICH MAN WHO AS ALWAYS
GET AWAY WITH OUT PAYING THEIR
DUES TO THE JUSTICE SYSTEM
SYSTEM.
>> Tucker: ALL OF US HAVE
LAWYERS.
ANIMALS NEVER INVITE MY LAWYERS
TO SPEND THE NIGHT AT MY THREE
HOMES.
>> NEITHER WOULD I.
I WOULDN’T STAY AT MY LAWYERS
HOUSE EITHER.
YOU KNOW.
>> Tucker: JUDGE JEANINE.